we made it we made it to the end of 2021
which means we all get to collectively
look back at a year of accomplishments
mistakes but most importantly all the
incredible games that we played and for
us here at gamespot that means the 10
best games of the year so just just
please know that we put a lot of time
and consideration into this list and it
is never easy to make but without
further ado here are the 10 best games
of the year according to the very
passionate people who love them so
[Music]
one last tango 47
hitman 3 feels like the apex of io
interactive's long journey to craft the
perfect hitman game every level in
hitman 3 is just a masterful example of
what makes a good hitman level from the
massive extravagant party in the
skyscraper in dubai the bustling streets
of china or the small intimate affair in
dartmoor manor speaking of dartmoor
manor also represents a moment where
hitman 3 takes a lot of risks by
introducing more story elements into
their missions no longer do you just
take on the disguise of somebody but you
get to now role play them more
intimately by being a detective and
getting to actually solve a murder
mystery if last year you were to tell me
that the best detective mystery game in
2021 is a hitman level i would have said
shut up take my money when can i play it
but the absolute best level in hitman 3
is the rave in berlin this is io
interactive taking off the training
wheels and asking you the player to take
everything you've learned in your
countless hours of hitman and apply it
to this one mission
you have no idea who your targets are or
where they're located but i think the
fact that iowa interactive is forcing
players to play this way for this
mission is proof of just how damn good
their level design is you don't need the
hud you don't need that information you
can follow all of the context clues in
their world building in their design and
you can accomplish your mission because
just every hitman level feels so
expertly crafted and real and just
it's so
masterful on its own hitman 3 deserves
to be on this list but when you consider
hitman 3 as the third part in what is
essentially one massive game that io
interactive has built for the last five
years you realize just how truly
impressive this whole experience has
been at the 2003 oscars the lord of the
rings return of the king was nominated
and won best picture and really that was
the academy recognizing that entire
trilogy for its amazing accomplishment
in film and that's how i feel about
hitman 3. it's not just an amazing game
in its own right but it represents an
amazing accomplishment for io
interactive and the medium of video
games the hitman world of assassination
trilogy i think will go down as one of
the greatest video games ever made and
certainly one of the best games of 2021
look at these dolls
almost forgot they used to be humans
do you want to know what this story is
really about huh
[Music]
playing in takes two is the most fun i
have had playing a game all year which
is kind of weird because ultimately it's
a game about a couple breaking up
but still cody and may they have been in
this relationship they've been married
for a long time but decide that it's not
working out and want to separate their
daughter trying to keep them together
accidentally cast a spell on them making
them these small dolls and they have to
work together to break the spell why'd
you look like a blood of clay why do you
look like a wooden doll it's one of my
favorite games of the year because it
demands a completely cooperative
experience and i don't just mean that
like oh i'm playing with my friend
it means you are playing with your
friend you each have to work together
and communicate so much in order to
progress it's wild i don't think i've
ever played a co-op game that encourages
this much cooperation you have to talk
and communicate to progress
on everything
lion oh no wait horse horse
but what i think that does is it creates
a really nice mirror to what's happening
narratively cody and mate are fighting
but they have to work together in order
to get back to their daughter also
gameplay-wise it does the mario thing
which i found really really effective
each room it's a completely different
vibe it offers different characters
different gameplay mechanics but in
terms of the mario
with a new gamepl mechanic and it starts
you off very simple and just when you
feel like you've got the hang of it the
challenge increases and increases and
then by the end
you and the person you're playing with
are just working in tandem it's like you
are one person and you get through these
really difficult either you know
platforming or shooting or chase
sequences together because you just
you're talking it through and you get
there and you feel that success and it's
done so so well and that is why it takes
two is one of the best games of the year
[Music]
now the next time that you blink
i'm gonna send you back
[Music]
the thing to remember about blinking is
well it's only a matter of time
before your eyes is
one of the best games of 2021
for two reasons really and it's
ultimately in the way that those two
things come together so well that that
makes it really stand out it tells a
story that is
universal it tells a story of regret and
of catharsis and
of
memories and false memories and
self-image and it hits on so many things
and it does it all in just
90 minutes which is really remarkable to
me and it already does all that so well
and i can't even tell you the things it
does later because i'm not here to spoil
it but in addition to all those
narrative qualities it has it also does
all of those special things and those
rare things through a
lens that we've never seen before in
games so it's if you if you haven't
heard of it it's a game that you play by
blinking
uh literally it tracks you on your
webcam and you blink to advance time and
you live out the life experiences of a
character named benjamin and from his
earliest days of infancy to much later
in life you see things
through his eyes and when you
blink it
skips time and so sometimes you won't
want to blink and because you're you're
cherishing a moment when you first got
your pet cat
and
you really want to dwell in that moment
and and but ultimately you have to blink
and and off you go and now you don't
know how much longer into the future
you're going sometimes it's a few
seconds or minutes later sometimes it's
years later but there's also those times
that that are uncomfortable and you you
don't really want to sit there and maybe
you'll blink to get out of them quickly
or maybe sometimes the game subverts its
own logic and it asks you to sit and
soak in that moment and even if you did
blink you can't move on yet and you have
to swallow that hole and you have to
grapple with it as if it's your memory
and to do either of those things i think
would already be remarkable and would
already be memorable for
to be one of the best games of 2021 but
to do both of them and to do it in only
90 minutes is just to me like nothing
has come close for me personally this
year it's just truly made it one of the
best games of 2021
[Music]
oh
returnal is a really fascinating game
that mixes a bunch of elements together
that feel like they shouldn't work but
do and is deeper than
most action games ever even try to be
and i really got lost in it this year
returnal is housemark a developer that
is known for
their bullet hell shooters doing third
person action games with all the same
bullet hell sensibilities and somehow
making it work in a way that doesn't
make you want to tear your hair out and
yet is extremely difficult and really
just exciting to play through but the
thing that i loved about fraternal
wasn't fighting these weird aliens on
this weird alien planet that weirdly
kept shifting with these sort of
rogue-like elements
where you just get lost in it and every
time you die and come back it's a
different place what i really loved
about eternal was the fact that the main
character is working through some weird
stuff in her own mind the story has
strange elements of mythology it's
mixing in some metaphor it's dealing
with personal trauma return hit me with
some of the coolest moments i had this
year it also expertly uses the whole
time loop idea that was really really
popular this year to put you through a
bunch of intense challenges but for you
to become a better player as you go and
mixing in those cool roguelike elements
to give you better guns to slowly
provide you with a better arsenal that
you still have to seek out in the world
it created this interesting mix of the
bullet hell ideas that house mark is
known for the roguelike ideas that have
been spreading out throughout the genre
and mixed together to make something
that was challenging but not punishing
and that's why returnal is one of the
best games of 2021
[Music]
okay
[Music]
resident evil village is one of the
games of the year because the game took
some of the best elements of the
resident evil franchise that's resident
evil 1 with its puzzle elements resident
evil 4 with some of its survival action
elements where merge that together and
the first person horror of resident evil
7
and mix those all together taking the
best elements of them putting them on a
silver platter and just serving it up
for us to eat into the game is just
fantastic at building up tension in
horror when it wants to with its various
lores which is just another one of the
elements that really stood out in
resident evil village which are its four
lords and the lore behind them has been
in viento and lady dimitresk
specifically has some really nice juicy
lore behind them and beneviento with a
nice tragic backstory and dimitresque
with a more vampire-esque one but just
reading into that and seeing the
build-up and the puzzle piece of reading
the item descriptions when lore come
together
really elevated the material and i just
love seeing that in a resident evil game
on top of that we got to find out a
little bit more about elements i don't
want to spoil in case you haven't played
the game because you really should but
elements about the lore that really
helped explain some of the absolute
weirdness and things that happened in
resident evil 7 and the beginning of
village that have you scratching your
head and now all that is explained and
tied up in a nice little bow so i really
appreciate about that about village all
of that together is why resident evil
village just stands out again as another
fantastic entry in the resident evil
franchise what resident evil village did
was take elements of all of the previous
games and then merge them together for a
totally unique experience and way to
play resident evil there's a reason that
this franchise has continued to stand
the test of time and be one of the names
if not the name
in horror in video games and resident
evil village just continues that and
that is why it is one of the best games
of the year and you should definitely
check it out if you haven't
go do it
this is where it all began
nowhere
this is where it all
ended
dad what are you doing here well we're
here to support you son
will we
we all make mistakes
why are you taking so
long
[Music]
i'm getting less sure i want to see this
oh no
i don't think you want to see this at
all
psychonauts 2 is a really deceiving game
on the surface it's this over-the-top
colorful funny ambitious 3d platformer
but the moment you start to peel back
the layers you reveal a game that's
really about second chances and
forgiveness and maybe above all else
it's about
at being empathetic and understanding to
the people around you
and those very concepts are seeded
through nearly every single aspect of
the game from the mechanics to the
character's motivations to the very
worlds you explore every single angle
and part of the scheme was meticulously
detailed to service its themes its
themes of mental health its themes of
acceptance psychonauts 2 takes all these
incredibly heavy concepts and packages
them in such a way that is so effortless
and approachable that it even takes you
a moment to really digest exactly what
it is that's going on in that game every
single level is the mind of a person
that you explore and each single person
like you and me battle with their own
problems whether that's ptsd anxiety
imposter syndrome it's all there but the
thing that makes psychonauts 2 so
brilliant and how it approaches these
rather sensitive topics is when you go
into these people's minds instead of
trying to solve their problems instead
of that kind of being the end goal
instead you walk away
understanding that person and where they
came from and better having an
empathetic idea of why they are the way
they are but even more importantly that
is what defines them into the wonderful
character
that they've become even the idea of
something like regrets and doubts and
panic attacks are the basis for the very
enemies that you fight in that game and
because it's done in such a colorful
fun humorous way that's never quite
spoon feeding it to you you can play
this game and just have a good time for
what it is but it's all the more
rewarding to actually take a step back
and take a look at the world and see how
every single concept just works in
complete tandem with each other it is
so
impressive even though psychonauts 2 is
the sequel to a 16 year old game it did
more than just exceed my expectations as
a fan of the original but instead stand
on its own two feet as a classic in its
own right and is more than well
deserving to be among the best games of
this year
okay
i'm gonna draw you now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
death loop gives you plenty of reasons
to love it whether it's the strong
characterization of colt and juliana as
well as the visionaries the fascinating
world of black reef or the beautiful art
design but for me the thing that really
stood out is the incredibly intelligent
design of the game as a whole
i love arcanes games especially the
dishonored franchise those first two
games as well as the dlc are some of my
favorite experiences of all time and i
play those games in a very specific way
as a ghost in out no alerts no dead
bodies fans the pure stealth run but
because of that style it meant i am not
able to engage in every aspect of the
game there are certain weapons abilities
and strategies that just aren't
conducive to that playstyle which means
there's a strong sense of fomo i have to
just be okay with not touching certain
portions of those games in death loop
however that issue is addressed from the
very beginning the trial and error
nature of the world which encourages you
to poke and prod at it and figure out
how the clockwork nature of it unfolds
and find the opportune moments for
yourself encourages you to experiment it
asks you to pick up every weapon find
every ability and use it and figure out
how it works also you can eventually put
together that perfect run right at the
end and when i got to that run it wasn't
a high chaos run i wasn't killing
everyone i had already done that it was
a pure stealth run so when i finished
the game i felt like i had played every
single facet of it and at the same time
i was true to myself
and i think that intelligent design
which looks at one of my biggest
problems with previous arcane games and
addresses it is why i think death loop
is one of the best games of 2021
salve friend i'm glarious mind telling
me who you are and what you were doing
in the shrine of preserving you're
probably wondering why i summoned you
just as the ocean accepts the rivers of
all the world
so this place accepts all the souls
if even one person commits a sin here
every last one of us will die welcome to
life under the golden rule
it's a ghastly thing is it not
the many shall suffer
for the sins of the one
forgotten city for me was
easily one of the most profound and
revelatory experiences that i've had in
gaming not only this year but i think in
quite a long while the whole concept of
this game is you falling into the city
where you learn that
basically there's only one specific rule
if anyone commits a sin any single
person
everyone gets killed and turned to gold
because you're from the future
you know that that is going to happen
and it's up to you to figure out
why everyone's going to turn to gold and
so that starts this really fascinating
mystery that just sets you off to just
go and explore and get to know these
brilliantly thought out and interesting
characters that all feel really fleshed
out all feel very real and yet at the
same time this game takes that like very
personified story and basically just
turns it into a philosophical argument
because the entire idea of this game is
to make you ask questions of what is a
sin who gets to define sins and it
starts to get you to ask questions that
philosophy and philosophers have been
asking for
for ages and it's really just delving
into that and making it philosophy feel
pertinent and immediate in a way that i
think few other games and stories really
ever have done and because it's a game
it allows you to invest in it and place
yourself into it and have your yourself
asked those questions in such unique
ways but also because it is a time loop
you're also allowed to within the
narrative of the game play around to
test the boundaries of these rules on
top of that the game's atmosphere and
way that it evokes different themes and
ideas are
so incredibly intelligent the way that
this game investigates ideas of cultural
appropriation of how we sort of build
upon other cultures in ways that are is
harmful steal from other cultures i
think is something that speaks to a lot
of issues today and i think that this
game just sort of makes that feel again
very immediate by looking at how it
happened in the past and then the game
just takes all of that and brings it to
an ending that for me
like goes to hit like a big home run and
just knocks it out of the park and just
ties everything together in a
really
awesome and satisfying and thoughtful
conclusion and so i think for all of
that
it makes forgotten city one of the best
games of the year
county for this mission does not seem
appropriate
this clearly outweighs the reward
[Music]
you are faced with overwhelming power
your highest priority should be simply
to survive
so metroid uh as a series is one of the
most um you know famous and renowned of
all time and that's for good reason it
basically invented a genre it
established a lot of the the
metroidvania tropes that we that we see
in basically all games and all genres
now and metroid dread it would have been
very easy for them to make another
metroid game that's just another metric
game what they did in metroid dread is
iterate on these ideas in in new ways
that made them fresh for newcomers like
young people who might not have played a
metric game before but were also really
surprising and engaging for people who
have played a lot of metroid games
there's a pattern to it um that's very
familiar to us what mercury steam did
with metroid dread is re-jigger all of
that they they completely subverted your
expectations uh my favorite example is
how they withhold the morph ball from
you for like half of the game to
long-time metroid fans like me that was
like well crap what am i supposed to do
now like i i feel lost i feel i feel
unequipped for for dealing with this
alien world and that's the feeling they
want you to have that's the feeling
that's core to metroid is that you are
you're alone on this planet and you have
to figure stuff out on top of that it
was a much more story focused metroid
game than i think we've ever seen before
it gave a lot more context to a lot of
the metroid lore and mythology that
we've seen throughout a lot of
past games and even material found
outside the games it closed the book on
this long arc of why it's even called a
metroid it started with hunting down the
metroids and then the baby and then the
the fusion suit and and now it's come
full circle with the metroid sort of
being becoming core to like who samus is
and so it's still going forward that for
as a metroid fan that's exciting so
it takes these tropes that we're very
used to it plays incredibly smoothly
with them while at the same time
subverting expectations and giving us
something new with that space it's
almost like they've seen the imitators
they've seen everyone come along making
their own metroidvanias and a lot of
those are great and i love them but it's
like they came along they were like this
is how you do one we're going to like
make one that is polished to perfection
and subverts what you think you expect
from this series uh and from this genre
and that's why it's one of the best
games of the year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we need to run
i need a weapon
halo infinite is one of the best games
of 2021 because it finally poses the
question of who
is master chief like this is a guy who
was kidnapped as a kid turned into a
super soldier and has saved the galaxy
numerous times and sounded badass while
doing it with some truly impressive
one-liners but that's what chief
does it's not who he is and when forced
to work with two new allies and infinite
chief has to like let his humanity show
in order to connect
to these people and secure their aid he
he can't relate to them as soldiers
because they're not fellow soldiers and
this opens up brand new story lines for
chief which is honestly when you think
about it kind of fitting considering
that infinite finally opens up halo for
the first time with an open world format
so focusing on this family dynamic in
the campaign between chief the weapon
and the pilot
allows infinite to have a more intimate
storyline it's one of the best that halo
i think has ever
had and it's really helped along by the
fact that the story plays out in this
open world that's gratifying to explore
and that kind of ties into the fact that
you have the grapple shot this grappling
hook that allows you to explore the
world in this
gratifying way with this phenomenal
momentum that translates over to the
multiplayer as well the multiplayer is
just
stupidly fun like infinite's multiplayer
is just really
frankly taken over the lives of numerous
people on gamespot staff it's just a joy
to play it's awesome to play into the
early hours of the morning yeah it's
it's as simple as that the sound design
for halo infinite is phenomenal the maps
and the online multiplayer are good
weapons hit with that like gratifying
kinetic punch and this is frankly the
best halo campaign that we've had in
years and for all of those reasons
that's why halo infinite is one of
gamespot's best games of 2021
and now it is my honor to reveal that
gamespot's game of the year for 2021 is
death loop
in the words of our very own lucy james
she said death loop is a game that has
taken the best of arcane's previous
titles and created something intensely
special in a year where time loops were
in vogue death loop has done more than
enough to stick out from the crowd
making it one of the best games of 2021
[Music]
now that that's all out of the way i
just want to take a second to reiterate
how hard this is for us as a team at
gamespot to make this list and whether
or not your personal game of the year is
here or not just know that we all
collectively show up together to enjoy
and celebrate this incredible wonderful
medium so with that way to go you made
it to the end of the year keep playing
games keep playing more games if there's
a game on this list that you haven't
played go and consider checking it out
alright
that's it thanks folks thanks for being
here
see you next year
okay
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you